[Musica]
ok mi sono cagato addosso è da tutti
ragazzi e bergomi di questo video sono
fa dj ed oggi siamo in un orrendo che
abbiate già notato che cosa ha
intenzione di fare perché ci sono
leggermente un po di pacchi dietro di me
or leave it ragazzi nello stesso luogo
vi avevo detto che avrei fatto uno e con
avrei aperto tutti i pacchi che che mi
sono rimasti perché no veramente
tantissimi ragazzi siccome la devo
aprire un casinò oggi ho deciso di
unirmi di attrezzi giusti no scherzavo
un coltellino sono un casino che ora
ragazzino devi partire dal primo che mi
sembra troppo figo perché c'è il
fiocchetto quindi alla precedenza ne
sono convinto che quando fischio di fare
sta roba la mia camera diventerà un
porcile però non importa ho trovato
navelli siamo un più anche questo lo
metto 41 e un già mi piace un casino
cos'è sta cosa
oh yeah yeah yeah con fiore bellissimo
foglio che ho scritto sorpreso non so
che cosa può essere ma mi immagino ora
fantastico tipo non ha commesso è un
troll
grazie mille sarà bellissimo ragazzo e
tutti noi veramente di olio sono più che
altro furie perché per voi non avete
idea che avere tutti quei pacchi è una
tortura perché non ai dati che cosa ci
sia dentro cos'è questo grazie dei
giornali molto gentile ed è per qualcosa
deve usarli non una collana di testi
bellissimi a chi cazzo è questo è una
presa ragazzi sai che se io vedo da voi
meno lanciati lo vado a prendere un kit
di trucco fantastico grazie lo devo
testare subito le prodezze di questa
fare allora terminati hogan si fa così
credo io prendo questo funzionano è
veramente troppo razzo sto facendo come
bambola ti andrebbe un po di schweppes
solo con me
e questi pacchi bellissimi portassi e un
libretto di orsetti questa si chiama
[ __ ] vi presento [ __ ] la scritta
thuraya quindi credo sia attrae lui
invece è che cazzo ragazze mi avete
inviato forse delle scarpe però non ne
sono sicura non c'è il cappello di
michael jackson grazie ad un tiro a
segno di homer simpson fantastico ogni
attimo che sono tipo un fenomeno a ste
cose e poi da bandierone l'italia
bellissima grazie fratello mi raccomando
la bandiera dell'italia sventola quando
ci saranno i mondiali
viva l'italia forza azzurri ai mondiali
dai che batte 4 0 il costa rica asta che
la perfezione indossa le cuffie l'asl
ende rella per questa di mancare il
cuore è fatto di pong ho sempre detto
che vi do il mio cuore per tutto quello
che fate per me quindi ragazzi questo è
vostro credo sia vostro diritto una
scimmietta con una mini banana è una
sciarpa bellissima c'è un numero di
conan fantastico cioè nomi che amanda
non ho mai letto una cornice che ho
scritto allora fa vj con il titolo renzo
sulla nutella questa me la prendo da
qualche parte i pavimenti ragazzi come
riciclare la scatola del due di esse per
fare un'altra scatola sei un genio caso
oddio brega cioè una zucca fantasma
bellissimo non so dove va a messa di pre
fase nella da mettere in testa una penna
e grazie a dio questa poi quella che
cercavano però io giuro non so come
faccia scrivere una penna così a e
assurdo ha fallite mi mancava per questa
è una chicca che quest'estate ci sta
tutto proprio invece un cat mario
leggermente morta e leggermente timido
ma che cazzo faccio ciò è leggermente
timido si sta solo cambiando addosso una
delle due
[Musica]
ok si è aperto credo si sia
effettivamente o perfetto ho trovato una
medaglia bellissima che era scritto che
il suo record numero uno non si sa cosa
credo in cucina o equitazione va beh un
po di tutto comunque non so precisamente
che cosa sia sta roba qui però è
decisamente ficcava quanto è bello
perché maria che col fiore era più figo
il mio di prima che se questo è sicuro
braccialetto mentro fantastico questo è
leggermente rosa però ma va bene lo
stesso c'è un pokémon veramente figo che
non mi ricordo il nome porca vacca
aiutatemi
no kids stile diventa un amica sta cosa
una figata diventa una pokémon che
figata rega quel questa è una delle cose
più figlie che io abbia mai visto giuro
e lo sognerà la notte alle cena avanti e
fantastico ho trovato un tot fantastico
cena da oggi sono immortale cazzo
d'accordo ragazzi siamo giunti al agli
ultimi due dopo secolo no perché prima
non riconoscevo più letto adesso ha
preso forma di nuovo ragazzi io non so
che cosa c'è qui dentro di preciso però
sento rumori metallici c'è un
transformers o qualcosa del genere non
ho capito è molto più che un
transformers i miei non dormono più da
dino una cintura nel perfetto ragazzina
da oggi in avanti soul karate so perché
ho questa che mi sono fatto malissimo
recchia l'intenzione c'era lo stesso
però questa cosa è una boccetta di
profumo è un profumo che l'orsa di
canebagnato non perché non mi stupirei
di quello che mi inviate sa di cannes è
bagnata sta roba
trollbeads aumentato st marca merita un
premio cioè bellissimo non ci posso
credere a un iphone è arrivato con
l'iphone per posta non scherzava una
calcolatrice pro sembra c'era un motivo
se sta roba si chiamava trollbeads e
spero ci come ultimo contenga cos'è
immaginare il manuale anti furbi
fantastico ma tipo anti formi significa
antianti questo
c'è il coso furbi e l'altra no che cosa
ci fa una foto di me la mia ragazza
chi mi ha inviato questo pacco non è
neanche cosa sia questo però è morbido
quindi è mio sesto cosa oddio mi sembra
ma è una caccola leggermente grossa o e
l'intestino di qualche animale non lo so
dall'odore credo sia un intestino di
qualche animale però a me piace lo
stesso chiodo ragazzi re che per oggi è
tutto scattato tipo non sarà una
quindicina di paki ce ne sono tipo il
quadruplo di là però direi che posso
concludere qui il blog visto che devo
mettere leggermente un po in ordine la
camera sono s'è visto ricordatevi
comunque convinto la medaglia numero uno
per per tosare le pecore credo quindi
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto come al
solito lasciate un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come ogni
video tratte nella descrizione servizi
vari siti scrive terni ci vediamo al
prossimo video da ragazzi poiché ragazzi
veramente quando fatto sta scena poi ho
provato a togliermi trucco ma appena ho
visto che non si toglie da te che hai
sguardo di rassegnazione propria
beh